Speaker 1: Welcome to the show.
What a big news weekend and so many different
things happening, the Kyle Rittenhouse case
is the trial is into closing arguments and
the jury will be deliberating.
We may have a verdict soon, we don't yet know.
We're going to talk about the case related
to the killing of Ahmaud Arbery.
There's wacky stuff going on there.
So many different things.
But one of the big pieces of news news elements,
I would even call it breaking at the very
end of last week and into the weekend is the
indictment of former Trump adviser Stephen
K. Bannon, who has indeed been indicted on
contempt for ignoring a subpoena from the
committee investigating the Jan. six Trump
riots and of course, wanting to know Steve
Bannon's role in that.
Given all of the public statements that he
has made very logical person that they would
want to talk to.
He ignored the subpoena.
He is indicted.
He is reportedly surrendering to authorities
today and will be arraigned.
This is a big deal, and it is yet another
Trump associate who has been indicted for
different reasons, of course.
New York Times reporting Bannon indicted on
contempt charges over houses Capitol riot
inquiry.
Stephen K. Bannon, a former top aide to Donald
Trump, had refused to comply with subpoenas
from the House Committee investigating the
January 6th attack on Congress.
Stephen came in and a one time senior aide
to Trump was indicted by a federal grand jury
Friday, two counts of contempt of Congress
after his refusal to provide information to
the House Committee investigating what you
and I and reasonable people around the world
know of as the Trump riots.
Bannon, who's 67 years old, declined last
month to comply with subpoenas from the committee
seeking testimony and documents.
The House then voted to hold Mr. Bannon in
criminal contempt of Congress.
The House referred the matter to the U.S.
Attorney's Office for a decision on prosecution.
Trump has directed former aides and advisers
to invoke immunity and refrain from turning
over documents.
A Justice Department spokesman said Bannon
was expected to turn himself into authorities
Monday today and make his first appearance
in Federal District Court in Washington later
today.
A lawyer for Bannon didn't respond to a request
for comment.
This is going to be a really, really crazy
period of time.
The Department of Justice putting out a statement
official statement about what they did.
Stephen K. Bannon indicted for contempt of
Congress.
Two charges filed for failing to honor House
subpoena.
Bannon indicted on two counts, which I already
told you one count involving his refusal to
appear for a deposition, another involving
his refusal to produce documents.
Remember that you can subpoena an individual.
You can also subpoena documents.
He refused to show up, and he refused to provide
the documents.
This I don't know that we really need to read
much more of the statement.
We continue to see a growing number of Trump
associates that have been indicted.
We now have Steve Bannon, Tom Barrack Elliott
Broidy, Michael Cohen, who is down to his
last 10 days or so of his home confinement
sentence.
Michael Flynn.
We're going to hear from him later in today's
program.
Rick Gates, Paul Manafort, George Nader, George
Papadopoulos, Roger Stone and Allen Weisselberg.
Quite a list of quite a cadre.
I guess we would say of characters there.
And the question continues to be, is this
going to reach Donald Trump ever?
I continue to believe it will not.
I continue to believe that the worst case
scenario for Trump would be some kind of business
problem.
I don't believe this is ever going to reach
Donald Trump, as you will hear in my comments
later on.
It is now being alleged by one of Trump's
former press secretaries that he would hold
off the books meetings specifically to circumvent
records laws to prevent there being records
about some of his meetings.
And arguably, that is a criminal issue, but
I just continue to believe that it is not
going to get to him, and it is not for lack
of deserving it.
It is because of the system and the political
forces that we have at play in the United
States.
So what is ultimately going to happen with
Steve Bannon?
We don't know yet.
The arraignment coming later today believed
to be and this could be.
There are now allegations being made that
there are subpoenas going out to Mark Meadows,
Trump's then chief of staff, potentially to
people like Stephen Miller and others, if
they will also attempt to.
That's the one other thing I wanted to mention.
What Steve Bannon did is staying loyal to
Trump.
As The New York Times reports, Trump directed
Bannon and others not to comply with these
requests for their physical presence and their
requests for documents to be turned over.
So Bannon is staying loyal to Trump now.
Trump no longer has pardon power.
Remember, Trump pardoned a number of different
people.
Michael Flynn's one of them who we're going
to talk about later.
Trump doesn't have pardon power anymore, so
either there is a play that Trump will eventually
be president again and pardon them if they
stay loyal.
That's a long shot.
It's not that it's impossible or implausible,
but it's a long game.
You've got to wait years for to see if Trump
is even going to run and then see if he's
going to be the nominee and then see if he's
going to win and then see if you'll pardon
me.
So that's a very long play.
The other part of it would be they just believe
ultimately they're going to get out unscathed,
and that remains to be seen.
But we'll see what happens at the arraignment
today and what the next step is here.
Maybe there is a timing out aspect.
Maybe Bannon thinks, OK, I'm going to get
indicted.
But in the time that my case will be pending,
the committee will be done and I might get
a slap on the wrist.
Probably not a big deal.
But I will have avoided providing testimony
or documents.
I don't know.
OK, I don't know what the legal strategy is,
but we're going to see very, very soon